[Music]
Google cloud offers a first-class
experience for Windows workloads that
can help you reduce your license cost
today we are going to migrate and
modernize a legacy web application built
on the dotnet framework to Google cloud
platform without changing the source
code doing so can make your apps more
scalable and more reliable while helping
to reduce operations costs we're
starting with this familiar ecommerce
shop it was built using the dotnet
framework version 2.0 and still works
we'll take the existing application code
and move it to manage sequel server and
windows containers on google kubernetes
engine the original pet shop
architecture is a typical application
deployed on a single VM it has two tiers
a presentation layer which is dotnet
hosted on iis on windows and a data
layer with for sequel server databases
deployed on the same VM we want to
modernize the presentation layer to
leverage the scalability and resiliency
of kubernetes by using containers
we can reduce the footprint of the
application and make it agile for both
day-to-day work and future development
but first we want to migrate the data
layer to a managed sequel server using
cloud sequel for sequel server in the
Google Cloud console will create our
manage sequel server instance there are
several details you will need to provide
such as the name of the instance and the
region you prefer be sure to create your
database instance in the same region
where you will run your kubernetes
cluster once the instance is created we
need to migrate the data bases with
import we can restore an existing
database backup file in this case we'll
restore a back file we already uploaded
to a cloud storage bucket we'll select
our file give it a name and import once
we do this for each of the four original
databases we can see the sequel server
instance and the databases right here
from the cloud console with cloud sequel
for sequel server we can use some of our
favorite tools such as Microsoft sequel
server management studio
we'll need to use sequel proxy to help
ensure the connection between our local
machine and cloud sequel is secure once
sequel proxy is installed we'll launch
it and point to the instance we just
created as you can see the proxy is
saying it is ready for connections we'll
use s SMS we'll provide authentication
details
note that the server name is localhost
this is because we use sequel proxy
which obstructs the actual address of
where the server is located after this
connection is established we can see the
databases and interact with them we have
now migrated our data layer to GCP that
means we can turn our attention to the
presentation layer and the dotnet web
application now we don't need to change
anything in the existing web app code
all we need to do is create a docker
file with docker container is a ssin of
our app is just three steps first base
off of the asp.net 3.5 base image second
step into the working directory of iis
and third copy the content of this
application into the container to build
the container image using the docker
file we just made we'll run the command
docker build on a Windows machine that
has docker CLI installed then to push
this new container image into the Google
container registry
we'll use docker push the Google
container registry is what will allow us
to reference this image in a kubernetes
cluster before we deploy the web app we
need to resolve one issue how to allow
the web app to communicate with the
databases our new architecture is built
around containers we can install the
cloud sequel proxy as a sidecar
alongside our web app this means that
the web app and cloud sequel proxy will
be on the same network and this will
allow the web app to communicate with
the database using a localhost as a
server so we'll need to update the web
config of our web app so it uses
localhost in the sequel server
connection strings and then rebuild our
container image and push it to the
container registry we'll also build a
container image for the sequel proxy
first we'll need a sequel proxy docker
file this time we'll base off of
Microsoft based container image for
Windows Server 24
then add sequel proxy to that and then
invoke the proxy and point it to the
sequel server instance in docker will
build the container image and then push
this image into the registry we now have
two images
petshop iis is the image of the web
application that was containerized and
sequel proxy sidecar is the sequel proxy
that allows the app to connect to the
manage sequel server will deploy the
application and the sequel proxy on the
same pod in a kubernetes cluster but
first we need to provide a Hamel file
that describes the state we want for the
containers fortunately we can use a
fairly standard boilerplate Hamel
the important part is the node selector
where we can indicate that we want to
deploy into a Windows node pool this
means that we want to deploy our
containers as Windows containers running
on a Windows node then we list the
containers we want to deploy the petshop
IaaS and sequel proxy side card images
we just made finally we'll expose this
application using an external IP will
use cube c dl to deploy our containers
and check the status of our web app
apply starts the deployment get services
list the external IP address of the web
app get deployments list our deployment
now living in the cloud and get pods
list the pods showing that the
application is up and running at this
point we've modernized our web app into
a kubernetes managed app running in pods
with one container for the.net app and a
second container for the sequel proxy
with secure connections to the manage
sequel server database the advantage of
an architecture like this is that we can
scale the two pods with a single cube C
DL command check the documentation to
get started and try it out for yourself
you